hi my name is Chris Wilson and the
director of data journalism at Time
magazine and at my talk data for
democracy is about how we use Wolfram
technology at time to better understand
the news through a computational
perspective
uh hi everybody my name is Chris Wilson
I am the director of data journalism at
Time magazine I am pretty sure I'm the
first working journalist to ever attend
the wolfram summer school because on the
first night I was there one of the
wolfram employees will go nameless took
me aside and said he seemed nervous
he said if if Stephen says only I'll
never forget his wording if Stephen says
anything alarming it won't go in Time
magazine right III said no no we will
consider this all three weeks off the
record but then for all three weeks I
was just sitting there thinking what
does Stephen know that we don't that is
so alarming and I never found out so but
anyway I'm very proud to be a working
journalist because there's so many
things that are not right with the media
right now we all know but that what we
need is to bring a more kind of to have
as much of a kind of intellectual and a
computational approach to the news we
need people who think like that in every
newsroom and so people often sitter ask
me well if you'd like computer science
so much why are you also in journalism I
see it actually as a wonderful marriage
of two ways of thinking and I was
reminded of this when I was rereading on
Stephens essay about Richard Fineman in
his idea makers book and talking about
how much fun and loved the process of
figuring things out as opposed to just
getting the correct answer to a problem
and that to me is very similar to the
way that you tell a story which is that
rather than just telling somebody how it
ends you want to tell them how you got
there
and so what I'm gonna show today is how
I used Mathematica to Howard this
article that ran on Monday in time which
is all about how many seats we should
have in the House of Representatives 435
is an arbitrary number we arrived at in
1929 after you know endless sort of
debates on who would get more seats and
so forth and the reason I picked this
example is that um I think it's a good
example of how Mathematica really lends
itself to telling a story in the process
of writing code which is what really for
me represents the union of the things
I'm interested in but also the the sort
of idea of the computational essay that
Stephan laid out on juice evening so you
certainly won't go through it line by
line but the most important algorithm
arguably ever is the way that we decide
how many representatives of the 435 go
to each state the Constitution is very
very vague on this it says everybody
should have one make sense there were
only 65 to start with thirteen states
and then other than that it just says
basically it should go according to
their numbers which it's interpreted to
mean their population and that now
includes everybody
we've tried five different algorithms
for doing this over the years and it's
funny to think of lawmakers arguing over
algorithms because most of them don't
understand then and yet still it's a
very different
how you wait who deserves to have how
many seats when it definitely doesn't
easily ground is actually quite
important the way we do is we give
everybody one bring the Constitution so
we have 385 lat
and then we give everybody a wait every
state a weight which is their population
divided by the geometric mean of the
number of seats they have so far plus
one times that number plus one and then
it's just this round-robin you just keep
doing this and as your parceling out
seats your recomputing the priority for
each state and so the first task here is
to just recreate what is legislation as
code because that's what functionally
legislation is the source code of
America but it's often very vague or
terribly written or impossible to
understand without a law degree and so I
we wrote the the function that for any
number not just 435 doles them out I
tested it on the number 435 I know it's
not super easy to read but it's not
really that important point being just
it works in the sense that if you
compare it to the actual number sure
does um anybody know how to do that
Oh yep thank you okay all right so one
point being just the first step was to
make sure that I hadn't made a mistake
by taking the actual number of
Representatives per state
subtracting it from the computed value
and making sure that they were all zero
that's just a you know a it's a respond
check but here's where it gets
interesting is this is the
number of the ratio that the number of
people per representative in every state
which ideally should the variance should
be zero but we have Montana on one side
which has almost a million people as of
the last decennial census and now has
over a million it has one representative
and then you have Rhode Island which has
only about three percent more people
than Montana but got two seats since
they're one and so it's got about half
the value and what it really comes down
to is just there aren't enough seats
that somehow Rhode Island was just a
little higher in the priority lists in
Montana probably Montana would have
gotten a seat if there had been you know
450 um but that's why the system is
broken is that we're using this
arbitrary number that we decided on
almost 100 years ago but so what was fun
about this and where we get into sort of
the computational scientist to say okay
let's just imagine what the variance
would look like for any current number
of seats starting at 435 where we are
and going up to 1305 which is just three
times as many and then using as the
dependent variable just the coefficient
of variance just very simple measure of
how equal then that bar chart looks and
it was really interesting that of course
you expect the fairness so if you think
of a lower value here it's just being
more fair in the sense that states
there's a more equitable distribution
[Music]
that you of course you expect it to go
down as you get more seats it would be
very alarming if you didn't but not it's
not remotely linear and there are these
strange junctions so the this
it's not contiguous either and so this
became a fun kind of investigation over
why is that the house kind of what why
is there 435 kind of broken so this is
just the exact same graph but just
identifying green points are like the
optimal values and red points are the
worst possible values such that if you
add one it goes the disparity drops
enormous ly and then looking at what is
in what is so these numbers zone up at
the top are just those green values and
looking at who gets the last seat in
this round-robin process and who would
have gotten the next one if the number
was one larger so first when you look at
the optimal values you see that they're
all very small states Montana Delaware
South Dakota those are all States just
soft on my head I'm a certain that
currently only have one representative
and they're getting depending on how
many seats you give them either two or
three whereas the next one if you had
one larger goes to a large state so we
actually do say that for Montana Montana
would get its second lawmaker which it
deserves given the population if there
were just five more seats for 440 and in
you know we can see that here in that
the disparity drops significantly after
just adding a couple of seats this is
the same chart I showed you just looking
at some of these different optimal
values and what's curious and we can see
this from the chart is that 930 is this
sort of magic number that is the you
know that the variance
doesn't get that much better when you
add another
300 ish seats but it's only a little bit
more than twice what we have now so this
is the premise that this is a
computational investigation journalistic
investigation that comes up with the
premise that I think is defensible and
many people who have tweeted at me do
not think it's defensible is that we
need nine hundred and thirty members of
Congress this was how things worked
until 1929 whereas more states were
added we'd always add more people the
population in the country is more than
three times what it was the last time we
added any members of the House then just
for fun I also ran it for 5,000 members
just to see and you see the variance
comes down to point zero one but that's
probably not a realistic scenario it's
kind of curious and so what we was able
to do then was write an essay that these
are all graphs you've seen before now
just rewritten in JavaScript for the
browser that are it's making the
beautifully written is making the case
as best I could to a not to an audience
slightly different than say this one
laying out why we need nine hundred and
thirty members of progress and I'm not
kidding when I say plenty of people were
nonplussed would be a polite way to say
this but um that it it's something that
I think people often sort of don't think
about it many people were just surprised
to learn that
4:35 isn't a number in the Constitution
it doesn't even require an amendment to
change it's just a while and so Congress
actually gets to decide how many seats
there are in Congress and and so it's
it's quite quite easy to change and is
overdue for a change but it required
taking a problem that and thinking about
it computationally which is really what
I went once emphasized in order to come
up with what I think is not bad a little
piece of journalism feel free to
disagree my twitter handle is Chris
Wilson DC and but but but just to sort
of belabor the point a little more the
the way the way I can formulate these
types of essays is by essentially
writing them in a notebook first and
making very deliberate use of the
formatting so you know give it a title
and and just work through argument so
there's a lot of those words in here
know computational power but this is
this is something that I do even if I'm
not presenting a notebook to a group I
might not spellcheck it quite as well
but I I i write out what it is that I'm
doing and the reason for it essentially
just making liberal use of comments in
any other coding language and it's just
really nice and Mathematica that um you
don't have to put all your notes between
a parenthesis and asterisks and so this
is both on the cloud and uploaded on in
some way but you're welcome to look
through if you if you so desire
but it's basically just laying out very
much what's happening in why and that
gives me a template for how to make the
argument the exact same argument in an
essay for a truly great American
magazine and I say that not because I
don't know if his live-streamed if my
boss is watching or not but um very very
very unlikely but but it is a wonderful
place people often ask me why if you
know I like coding so much and going to
a the last standing weekly news magazine
and I said that it is the most ethically
pure example journalism I've ever seen
where they we are so intent on being
fair being on nonpartisan and reaching
as many people as possible not just
because you want you don't want half up
here readers unsubscribing but because
you need to reach everyone and if you
can't reach everyone then you're not
doing something right and that actually
is so fairly nice marriage I've one or
two other examples but only rigged
question um there's another function in
another notebook somewhere that does
this and not much is the short answer I
live in in DC and we have about seven
hundred and thirty thousand people who
live physically in the district which is
larger than the state of Wyoming I think
that would be it
it's is roughly smaller than Delaware
larger than Wyoming and so we and
Frederico as well would get beat sort of
towards the end of the priorities and
probably get one seat
under the current allocation that seat
would probably come from North Carolina
I think I think they're the last one in
the line right now and I should also say
that what another thing I did was you
know this directly informs the size of
the electoral college this add to to
every number and there wasn't a single
scenario that changed the outcome of the
2016 election even when there are two
states Nebraska and Maine that split
their electoral votes by congressional
district for the and then give the two
belonging to senators do the statewide
winner even if you sort of try to
simulate that nothing changes because
the winner-take-all system of the
electoral college makes it really kind
of trivial when you increase the size so
this is much more about having a
sensible representation as opposed to
changing the outcome of elections or
anything like that well so that would
require a constitutional amendment and
that that would require I think kind of
a reckoning of do we deserve to have a
body that is more powerful that is
agnostic to population and I'm not
certain the answer is yes but that is a
core principle that was decided upon by
1789 and I think it's fairly unlikely to
change unless you came up with some way
that you sort of weighted people's votes
differently or something so it's really
kind of my mine on the answer is let's
fix the house see how much better
everything gets and then apply it to the
Senate by all means I mean the question
is basically how do you legislate
computation
and if it were for me I would say I mean
you know you can't really upload a
notebook to legal system but you could
come up with a way to describe this
approach where so you know when when we
were looking at the optimal values here
the reason I chose 930 was not because
it's absolutely the best 930 is right
here is because it just is close to the
best it's a few people you have to add
to get to what resembles the local is if
you think of the green dot says local
minima then um you see it's basically
the smallest value that gets you the
biggest return I'm sure you could
parameterize that some way for sure
absolutely because the the census
publishes fairly reliable state-by-state
demographic projections they're pretty
good up through five or ten years and
then they go through forty and just is
impossible to say but um yeah yeah no
they don't know about the aliens
but um you could certainly I mean you
could you could even do something even
simpler which is just look at the vector
from the previous decennial and say okay
you drew this much in the last ten years
let's assume you know you're heading in
that same direction but that that is
less important to me than figuring out a
way to say basically how to defend the
fact that nine thirty is the best but
I'm sure we could come up with something
that you could either say any number
less than a thousand or just
the sum ratio of the number of seats
you'd have to add versus the benefit you
get from it and you optimize that value
I what prompted me to attend the summer
school so I've been trying for about ten
years I'm self-taught I've no no
credentials but I saw a video about the
release of machine learning algorithms
in Mathematica which I had never heard
of before um one of the things that
Mathematica really needs better
representation in my industry and
industries like mine which have nothing
to do with science err and arguably
sometimes antithetical to it but that um
because I I tried to teach people I I
offer a optional class for all of our
interns on how to learn to code just
because it's good and it's good job
security usually they only attend the
first session but and but and we're
doing in JavaScript just because that is
the only option right now and but it's
really hard to get them to understand
why they should want to to know this
whereas if I could have them all running
Mathematica then you just get to see the
product of your work so much faster and
so I I was really really intrigued by
this whole concept and I heard of Steven
but didn't know a whole lot about him so
I actually was gonna write a story on it
and they connected me to Taliesin Benson
and he's like why just come to summer
school and he ended up being my mentor
and it's a great friend who doesn't
respond to a lot of email and but it's
it's three of the most rewarding
weeks that I can pick up that's at my
head and in in the recent past just
because I you know I hate people around
work describing this are you doing space
yeah and I was like basically but but
but just I kind of felt like I'd found
my people and I would love to go back
sometime I when I've you know accrued
enough fun good but you know enough
moral points to also to once again
disappear for three weeks
thanks for Bali I I know I know I'm not
supposed to be up here anymore but I'm
going to show you just this is just a
preview of something it's the wrong one
that is forthcoming which is I'm really
interested in trademarks because they're
this window into anybody who tries to
register anything as a trademark it gets
put up on a very poorly designed website
run by the US Patent and Trademark
Office but it's just window into how
people think about marketing and so when
one funny example is is is how people
try to try to take an existing slogan
and me so these are we found 300
examples of people who had registered a
trademark since Donald Trump first tried
her first did that was just make XY
again that was the only thing you had to
you didn't have to have either America
or great but they but but anyway I'm
you know but this is a real thing I mean
FCA Network whoever they are and so the
thing I'm looking at now is how precise
you can choose to say that color is or
is not part of your application it's
harder to get approved you say color but
it's also a very arbitrary process but
you see these things like this is a
masonry company in Des Plaines which is
leased in the same state as we are now I
know but I I think it's pretty obvious
that they are trying to invoke sort of
Starbucks there you can you can argue
with that but the colors are certainly
very close and so I took everything
everybody that mentions the word green
used a bunch of stuff to basically
reduce from the 16 million impossible
values in RGB and came up with this is
sort of fun a product of the all the all
the greens that on our trademark and by
frequency with some clustering and so
that'll I know that'll be fourth grade
but you can see the some of the examples
thing thank you so much I'll be hanging
around